So to answer this, let's think about the pseudocode we add before. We have this while loop,
where we need to know as the stopping condition if date1 is before date2
and then we have the body that keeps incrementing the date. Well we've got
our procedure now to do this part. We implemented the nextDay, that we're ready
to turn into code. If we're going to write a helper procedure, we should write
something that makes it easier to do this date comparison. And that's going to
be a lot better to do as a helper procedure than to try to do that inside the
daysBetweenDates code. Knowing whether a date's before another date is
something that is possibly useful, in other context we'll actually see another
use for it in writing this. The other advantage of writing that as a separate
helper procedure is we can test that separately. So instead of starting by
writing daysBetweenDates right away, it would make a lot more sense to start by
writing helper procedure that determines the stopping condition. So, let's do
that. We're going to write a procedure dateIsBefore that takes as inputs, two dates,
still encoded as three values. And it's going to return True or False,
telling us whether year1, month1 and day1 is before year2, month2, and day2. If
you weren't able to write the code for daysBetweenDates on your own, now that
you've heard this hint, please try again. See if you can do it writing
dateIsBefore first. And testing that that's correct before you go on to writing
the daysBetweenDates procedure. I'll show you my code next.